[Music]
when i was a younger man a friend of
mine kate sims's her dad would kind of
hire me to drive his cars from florida
back to connecticut when the seasons
changed he was very generous with me he
gave me you know money for
obviously gas and all that and a little
bit extra to stop at hotels but i had
very little money at the time so i
wanted to conserve the money and so i
would find the cheapest motels possible
you know highway rest stops 22 a night
and then i drive up the street and i'd
find a 19 a night one and i would but
the 22 night one was a little bit nicer
so i would go back to the fewer pubic
hair on the pubic hairs on the pillow
yeah still quite a few but you know and
i would go back and i would haggle with
and this is like they must have hated me
i mean these
proprietors who ran these places like
proprietors at like two and three in the
morning i'd be like well you know that
guy is actually charging 22 for the for
the come on in motel that guy is 19 and
can you give me this one for 19 or 18
even and sometimes they would i would
get like that kind of deal christian and
i should have prefaced by saying we come
from a family that cuts a lot of kills
you are your mother's son she's a coupon
cutter coupon coupon coupon here's the
show
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to the life is short
i'm your sometimes quite frugal
thrifty okay almost a cheap life could
be a dream
[Music]
and with me as always is my less thrifty
but you got your hands down but still
thrifting uh-huh you you know the value
of a dollar
you appreciate the value a value of a
poo dollar
yeah that might not make sense for
people who don't know your instinct your
instagram handle handle
um you we grew up our mom was very
conscientious about spending money she
to the point where we've talked about
this before she'll go to two or three
different grocery stores to buy two or
three different ingredients for a meal
the craziest depending on which where
the craziest part of that story of like
the 19 hotel room story that's nice you
to call it a story it's a story there's
a beginning middle in it
the craziest part of that story to me is
that
relatively speaking you have a lot of
money now relative to then and relative
to the population yes of this country
and i wouldn't be that shocked
if you pulled a move like that now um
yeah you know
not a 22 19 right i've gotten more
precious but like 150 120 dollar move
for sure oh yeah why are we talking
about you being cheap and being
a young driver a baby driver if you will
our guest today was one of the stars of
baby driver uh edgar wright's baby
driver
what a great movie uh our guest today is
asa gonzalez
well you know she was she's a friend of
mine and she was here for a couple days
hanging out in fact we did the interview
with her it's the first guest we've had
in the podcast room it's very exciting
uh but i took my seat yes she did yeah
we look different
slightly it was christians making a face
and even you don't even need to make
that face to look like radically
different
uh yeah you look quite different um
but she uh was she was
like for some reason i couldn't
get a grasp on how exactly to pronounce
her name and it was like do you ever
have those moments where it's like um
it's like oh well uh it's umami oh you
mean umami no no umami yes umami yes no
no no um to her you're saying it
completely wrong i was i it sounded
exactly right so i'd be like
how exactly did you say she was like
it's ace and she's such a great i mean
she she rolls she is like um
rolling her arms i'm only asking if it's
a z sound
it's supposed to be so i thought
she's like think about it like this like
ace
like a so you know what it is it's
e-i-z-a so if in spanish it's exactly
pronounced the little spanish i know
explain this the vowels it's a e
okay all right well i'm glad we got that
claire but she goes she responds to
ace i had been calling her aza i my
favorite nickname for her which maggie
came up with is easy easy g easy g
because uh she you you hang out with her
and you realize that's very fitting
she's there's something very easy about
hanging out she came to our town
and we all hung out and we went to a
bilber
outdoor socially distant stand-up comedy
show which was so fun so um and we all
had a great time and we had a great time
getting to know her i had never met her
and she was really fun to hang out with
and yeah we hadn't really hung out with
another person in this environment uh
during it was weird i felt like i
haven't been social
in god it feels like well it has been it
has been a long six months but like this
is this is her real charm is that she
was able to blend in into an environment
like this which is unique so like
effortlessly and i've seen her then in
much different environments i actually
met her on a like a field trip with a
group we'll talk about it called this is
about humanity we went to the border um
we went to
uh bring food and kind of cheer to like
uh kids stuck in detention centers
mirth yeah dare i say we brought some
earth uh what they're working on earth
in spanish i wish i knew
felice is happy um contenta is
i don't know
duolingo is really paying off for you uh
it was you know speaking of duolingo i
like i had
i had a little bit of pride i was
getting a little prideful about learning
you know i'm learning the basics of
spanish and then having asa around was
like
acer around was like oh i don't know i
don't know anything and the way she and
she also speaks fast forward well you're
about to hero fashion oh yeah yeah um so
but anyway this is about humanity was a
day that we went and um that's where i
met her and she was so just so fun such
a fun person to be around uh very bright
like fascinatingly bright the way she's
um
her grasp of language and her how
intuitive she is
so if you haven't seen baby driver you
should um but you might also know her
from oh right hobbs and shaw is it hobbs
and shaw i believe so
i think it's hobbs shaw it's the
spin-off of uh fast and furious oh i'm
thinking of calvin and hobbes
it's not calvin
no it's um she was also in the tv
version oh yeah oh from dusseldon yes
and she uh which makes sense because she
bears uh i would say a fairly striking
resemblance to salma hayek who is they
do resemble each other well
i mean especially when she was sitting
here part of her face was obscured
anyway well she looks more like salma
hayek than i look like something is that
her such an understatement
yeah that's fair i would accept that uh
she
and and if you don't know her now she's
in all of these big movies coming out uh
and by the way you're about to get to
know her she's on the precipice uh and
she's just one of my favorite people um
i can't wait for you all to meet if you
don't know her already
the lovely
charming
uh very funny
gonzalez
life could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello again so we'll meet again
[Music]
what was the first time you were like uh
i want to do this i want to be a
performer it all started with singing it
was definitely my first love and
singing was part of around the house
yeah like i would sing around the house
a lot and my dad picked up on it and my
dad was actually a good singer oh yeah
um ever do anything
no he just was a good singer he had a
good ear and he loved music like very
well versed in the music world
it was fun and that's how i became like
i love 80s music 70s music is my
favorite 60s um
but long story short that's how it
started and then
um
very publicly known my dad passed away
when i was young and
my mom started putting me in all these
extracurricular classes and one of them
was um musical theater which made sense
for her oh you hadn't done that before
never
no never acted never acted before wow
and so she just had me gymnastics
dancing classes like 24 focus yeah just
mentally busy so i wouldn't you know get
depressed and
she
one of those was musical theater and it
was weird justin it was i mean i guess
not weird it just felt
like
and i looked back at it and i remember
because i sat my mom down and i was like
i need to have a very serious
conversation with you she's like about
what i'm like i like you as a kid
sitting here down yeah and i was like i
don't have to look no more this is what
i want to do for a living and i think
that for my mom
it was such a wild i mean
even i couldn't imagine being her you
know just
sitting there and being like
okay right wondering what do you know in
life
but i feel like luckily for me my mother
was just so
sad and wanted me to be happy
that she kind of did things that i would
look if i look back i'm like how the
hell did she do that like i wouldn't
have allowed my kids like she let me
drop out of school
she let me what age
that takes a lot of and
my dad passed away at 12 and 13 like at
14 i dropped out of school it's not like
your mom was i mean you did you were
telling me the other day she's not in
any way like a stage mom or like um
pushy at all this was your doing that it
was my total doing if anything i was the
one pushing her poor woman
but she you know she came to see me in
my
show i remember we we did grease and um
in your school yeah and like that
musical thing that i was doing it was a
summer camp
she came to see me and she was just
really mood and i don't know man i've
not been a mom so i have no no i was
never the guy oh you were there
of course
until the day
um but yeah so she she just you know she
let he she lit up and she saw that i was
the happiest she ever see me and
so she just rolled with it and she said
the moment you want to jump off the
wagon we're off like you don't feel
obligated for me or anybody no one ever
has to force you to do anything you
don't want to do this was purely because
you were dealing with it was in the wake
of this
awful thing in your life and so like if
anything brings you joy it makes sense
that she would want to foster that that
thing that brings you joy yeah because
it was probably so needed yeah and i
mean i don't know it's always
interesting to hear
child star stories right because
there's like the successful ones or the
non-successful whatever people consider
to the non-successful right because
it runs the gamut as you and i have both
been in the industry
um you can come
come in like oh so well put together and
then it can go sideways like there's no
right or wrong especially in the arts
especially in the world especially with
children but so i i would say the
majority the stories don't end that well
with kids who have success at that age
yeah and for whatever i mean we get into
all the reasons for yeah and that's just
that was something that i really look
back at and
i always try to credit my family and my
mother and my brother and honestly even
until the day that my dad was alive how
they raised me and the values and morals
that they
really embedded in me and they just
stuck and you know i was already very
responsible young girl i i gotta say
like i do have to credit at least myself
on that because
that was my success it's like okay if i
get to work and then i am independent
and i am responsible
and she doesn't have to wake me up to go
to work and be responsible she has one
less thing to worry about because she
had a lot in her and what was she doing
that she was running the mo yeah she was
running the agency but you know she she
was left with everything that my dad
left behind so she had to figure out her
company his company deps work
putting being a single mom of two
getting everything done
and and you know she she was just she
was overwhelmed oh bad yeah it's your
husband and and it was you know yeah it
was hard for her how quickly do you
become so successful that you're
traveling around and you're known like
how does that happen it was wild man it
was quick it was really quick and i was
so not ready for it and it's both a
blessing and a curse because it was
incredible i was able to
you know keep my mind busy and excited
and as i was telling you right that we
were talking about control and having
control over my life because my dad
passed in a motorcycle accident so that
was a complete loss of control so all i
wanted to do is have control in my life
and being an actress really was
life was letting me have my own blocks
and building blocks so that was really
healthy mentally but at the same time i
was just so scared so fragile so not
ready to be propelled into
everyone else's opinion obviously
also people don't know yeah lessons
during a time where and grieving and
you're playing your character apart you
told me that you compared it to kind of
like you were hannah montana in latin
america yeah and which is
buoyant and upbeat and i'm you know uh
like you said a role model like it's
something that kids immediately
gravitate toward yeah and that was so
scary because you're a child yourself so
you're like you don't even know who you
are is there anyone around you like a
manager or somebody who's like
directing that
person my mom was just very
well yes
are you a part of a little package
you're a little part of a machine like i
remember they signed me for at the time
nothing because i was unknown so there
was
a talent show
no i so i went to a school in acting
school which was inside like a lot like
inside of warner brothers let's say
and it was like a soap opera place and
it was the guy that produced it had just
done a super highly successful soap
opera called
and it was massive like everyone grew up
it was like
our vision our version of save by the
bell he was a humongous producer at the
time and he was looking for the new girl
for his new show
and i was honestly justin i mean i am at
the time 14.
i'm not thinking oh i want to be a star
i'm just happy to be here you know
yeah and so it was really you know
you've gotten to know me and you know me
pretty well because we've been friends
and for a while and and the thing was
like
i was always this upbeat and i would be
dancing and singing on the walking to
like lunch and i'd be like belting and
like laughing with my cackle and i
always had that personality it's amazing
that you maintained that in in the wake
of such a
horrific thing that you were able to be
that well i was just happy to be here
you know i was just like wow i'm chasing
my dreams this is amazing life has a
there's a silver lining like that was
the attitude is very if you look back at
it like i look back at myself like a
little hug to that girl because she was
just like trying to push through and i
would walk the lunch place was like
three buildings away from the building
that we went to school and we would
always see him his name is than me and
it was like oh my god what is this pedro
because he was the guy that created like
the big teen success because he talked
about it you speak spanish faster you
were saying the other day
wow
yeah yeah and so he saw me i was walking
down singing and like he saw me a couple
times i went a little louder when you
were passing him oh oh i was singing all
the way always so loud always like i
mean me on like steroids right now
he saw me and then i like got an
audition and then i got and he went did
he come right up to you no no it was
like a general yeah never personally no
no that's creepy and it was massive it
was like a search for seven months and i
auditioned for like seven eight months
seven eight months and at the time i
just was like oh i'm going to get a
little role in the soap opera this is
amazing i was so excited i you never
knew what you were auditioning for oh oh
interesting because soap operas there
are cute still right like huge huge but
this was like different to like regular
soap operas it was like you know like
when you hear disney searches like yeah
kind of vibe it was like say by the bell
makes sense it's a good frame of
reference kids coming in and millions of
kids from every point
it was cattle calls for sure so i had
honestly dude i had no idea i first of
all never thought i was gonna get
anything so you you were you do you
remember being like nervous or how did
you feel it was not because i honestly
wasn't the st
it was like in the early 2000s so like
the beauty standards and the looks of
standard like
was not who i was so i never thought oh
you're going to get it
yeah you didn't think you were in the
room i was like i'm going to get one of
the roles because it was like there's a
lot of kid roles there was a lot of
roles in the soap opera i'll get the
like buoyant happy-go-lucky chubby bro
yeah i was really excited to just do
that and uh
i remember
they took a picture of me and they
released it and then it was like boom
like if i was thrown into a different
stratosphere it was the weirdest thing i
went from
complete never had done any job in my
life not like a small role here nothing
well you did greece you played rizzo
yeah school of production so you were
ready
yeah okay there you go each of our
parents was there um and so i was not
ready just and everyone had an opinion
of me if i was
good not good great talented not
talented pretty not pretty oh the next
thing must have been oh my god
and you know i was a normal girl i had a
normal body i had like 14 year old girl
body i was like chubby in the cheeks
chubby didn't wear makeup like i didn't
care probably actually good for kids to
see that i mean you must have been like
in that sense a good role model unless
they made you like lose weight it was no
it was great but then you know it wasn't
like it is now which i really feel so
happy that this has changed because body
shaming was just so not like it was
really overlooked people would do it all
the time
press would do it all the time and no
one would call the press on doing that
so every time was like
it was weird it was weird and it really
created a dysmorphia with who i was
supposed to be because
the truth of the matter is i went
through a really deep depression when my
dad died and i gained aggressive amount
of weight from depression because i went
through like 12 to 13 eating i started
eating compulsively and my mom who at
the time you know she owned a model
agency
unlike people's opinion or thoughts that
what she did she never brought awareness
to like you're gaining weight or you're
never like she just never mentioned it
she let me be
um she let me
she was working on my emotions in a
different way but she never made a point
of like looks or how i should look or
should i lose weight or should i never
so i went from being completely unaware
of these things like hyper awareness
insanely oh my god
like day to night like that for 360.
what does that feel like what does that
do to you as a kid 15. well that makes
me never want to have children in the
industry listen it was a wild times and
then also at the same time i like never
i was like singing in the hallways but i
never sang in front of a stage so i
didn't even know how it worked i know
what an in-ear was i didn't have
training i was like a not like a normal
girl that had like some here in their
talents but i didn't have training as
far as most people know i've seen i've
been with you to mexico i've seen how
people react to you that the kids know
you you are known as that person by most
people so that's and you want to live up
to that because sure you want to live up
to who they are i i had this
conversation with someone recently about
like i remember the moment that that
glass shattered
the famous glass shattering for like
child stars towards adults we publicly
we're yeah when people are like oh it's
not her this is not her yeah you know
and i remember um
how it started happening and it's scary
like
i love to talk about this because it
brings awareness to mental health and
like all these things of like
you know you always hear like you're a
public person this comes with your job
or like these things right but you don't
realize what you signed up for yeah you
don't really think about like that the
traumas going through your head because
it feels like
oh wow i built up to this i worked so
hard this is i i've put my life into
like being this person and living up to
what people want because the
two-year-old kid who saw me
this is the idea so i have to be happy
all the time and smiling you have a
responsibility to all of these people to
countries do one thing yeah
fix it and then you are like a pointed
finger at you like being like bad girl
bad girl doesn't that reveal i mean now
you know like you
know how fickle that it reveals how
fickle that celebrity is that like
persona whatever that is that image that
people have it's not real not real yeah
it is real
breakable you were and i think that
that's what really has stuck with me
throughout years is
how till the day people still hold who i
was at 15. it's crazy yeah it's half of
my life it's literally 15 years ago i
was 15. and still is like you don't look
like you did or you don't act like you
did or you don't behave like you did and
all these things
it's like why are we living why are we
not allowing people to become who they
and this is the other thing if i like
vented everyone's problems or mistakes
throughout those years or their lives
yeah we all oh my god oh my god can you
imagine the truth you gotta think these
are high school years like if people
start like what the cool kids in school
say now amplified to everyone on planet
earth there was a thing when i was in
college the first time i ever
encountered anything like uh tabloids or
anything it was called the gossip
servers it was the very first there were
gospels and they just talked about
gossip on the campus this is like a
small liberal arts school two thousand
people
but i used to look at that and think
like whenever i'd see my name in a top
10 good or bad i'd be like oh whoa
they're talk there's something i
remember feeling a little charge a
little surge of like little serotonin
burs where my ego was
excited by that by being talked about
and then people say bad things and then
that's who
i invested in it and and there were
moments in my career and i'm sure you
can commiserate where like
you you've if someone says bad you read
a bad review or even like idiots on
social media saying things like i invest
in those things sometimes yeah and you
know how do you not i mean what's
happening
i've indulged in it on the other side
like as an audience right like i
remember when you know
public breakups and you're like i'm
assuming
oh yeah no idea i know like i'm such a
little gossip queen sometimes we're like
did you hear the news yes yes and then
you like we are all guilty of it i'm not
guilty people for doing that because you
know whoever designed us decided to put
that
weird mormon in us that we want you know
what's weird you know i'm reading i'm
reading this book sapiens and it's about
good you've got
yeah so they talk about that how like
how we survived homo sapiens versus
erectus or and it's because par they
think one theory is that like
we were just more prone to gossip and it
was a we were so we were able to
congregate in larger groups in groups
and yeah you're like gossip was very
important to our survivor it's in our d
it's in our like dna like crazy
yeah but it makes sense it's like a
gathering thing like i you know so many
people gathered a gossip and like i get
it right i get it there is this
dissociation that happens that it's
weird i like would be interested to see
what actually chemically happens to your
brain because
you know there's stories that you and i
have talked about like outside we'll
talk about i'll tell you about my one
relationship and it's like
this whole story and then you hear
what's out there and it's such a
different story and then people have
opinion about that story and then you
start kind of believing it like wait a
second i know the real story of course
it's a dissociation would that happen
that's difficult for me because i want
to talk about control we're going to
control a lot like i want if i want to
at the very least be able to control uh
an untrue if there's an untruth out
there that is painting me
that's what i've cried over the most i
think i've not cried about like what
people have to say about me my looks but
like
false narratives about me is what's
really gotten me
good because you know
that reflects on your parents
yeah that's exactly i like i have such a
high regard of my parents like
they did man like they did i i have
nothing bad to say about them and they
were incredible parents luckily because
i know that you know that's not always
the case and so i am grateful for that
and
one thing i've always i can be anything
people can say anything about me but my
my values and my morals are something
that i hold on to dearly like and that's
part of why i never did drugs right like
it was something that i knew that if i
were to try them like it's amazing i
would it was scary it was scary because
i was like maybe it'll turn me into
something that i might lose that and
that's something that i couldn't it goes
back to control when i started working
my
work became my sacred grounds where like
i could actually
be
fully who i was because it's like i i
whatever thought my persona is this and
i had work put so much work into it wait
wait what do you mean you could fully be
yourself it was like a refuge for i mean
i know it was a thing that you channeled
so much into to to get away from
something but but
because i started finding myself through
the arts right like i hadn't been able
to like sleep uh cry for four years over
my dad's death and slowly the arts
started allowing me to do that wow then
i started discovering that that persona
was not who i was also gave me
knowledge of who i was oh that makes
sense there was all these learning
things that came with but i've always
been who i've been from day zero like
the same asa from day one is the same as
now and so when i
had the transition to come to america
that was very scary because i it was
like uncharted territories and i am
you know i i
just got involved in situations that
were
so
not a reflection of who i was life could
be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and would
shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
[Music]
in this huge part of the world latin
america i mean
even though you you had that and and
you're being celebrated and i'm sure
people recognizing you and stuff you
have that experience that the very few
people have you still looked at america
as like well that's where really no no
no no no no no no oh no no no i
my story to coming to america is crazy
it's not even i never thought what did
you think of america stand on it so i
didn't plan on it but but what was your
perception of america then and it was
not a real world thing because the only
person that had crossed over latina in
the last 30 years had been selma
oh my god there was no reference there
was zero reference there was no reality
of like that's a possibility i mean we
had alejandra we had a couple of really
incredible actresses
but
alejandro no we had like a bunch of
actresses like i was like
we have alejandra we had men but we
really didn't have women and so
to me growing up i was just happy again
happy to be here like i was happy to be
working in mexico i wasn't looking to
like leave my country and go to america
never and i don't know i've ever even
talked about this so the way that it
happened
the way that it happened for me is
bananas
so i was in a relationship at the time
and i was really heartbroken and
it was just the one thing and i think
this is a great thing to say because it
also adds to why i never and i've always
been so publicly private about my
personal life because i did that mistake
once and i will never do it again i was
very public with a boyfriend in mexico
and
in um yeah like around that age and you
know because you're like trying to
appeal to society because everyone's
like she's going to be a society you're
like a mess at that age jesus
what do you mean you want to show them
that you're in this good relation you
want to present it good yeah i'm
you're just like floating you're trying
to float you're trying to stay afloat
long story short our relationship
started because of i opened that door
then press started to lie a lot about
our relationship i i just want to say
this relationships are not that juicy
like you know this
so all these juicy stories about like
drama were being sold that weren't true
and it was dry it was really depressing
me because this is such a poor
reflection of who i am but i also have
to not address it because if i address
it i'm playing into it and so what's
this what are you stuck with
yeah you don't do anything you follow
the depression because it's like this
persona being sold of who you are versus
who you really are and so i left i
couldn't do it dude i was overwhelmed i
just couldn't you left mexico entirely
so i grabbed me i grabbed a bag and my
friend at the time was renting this
little room in the back of a super cool
landscaping woman
this is way before airbnb airbnb didn't
exist it was like random this airbnb was
like hey do you mind if i crash
but i don't know this person so my
friend was like i'm in new york at the
time you should just stay at that little
room i'm renting at this lady's house
so then i moved and i
spent a week and a half depressed in
that room crying i was so depressed and
i went to l.a because you know i'd
always i always had some kismet feeling
with la because i liked music i grew up
going to the warp tour and like i liked
it i felt like very rock star glamour
like i was more into being a rock star
than really an actress at a point in my
life was there any crossover with that
was there like an element of that in
what you did as a singer like touring
around what was the name of this it was
just lola and then it was like yeah i
did a couple of things but
no i never really did it was more
disney-ish it was more like upbeat like
kids girl like nothing that i sang it
wasn't more that's why i hate when
people are like i want to listen to
music it's like not that i that was
great but it's nothing it's not it's not
me you don't have a personal connection
to it yeah yeah yeah it's not amazing my
choice of voice my choice anyway yeah
the whole point being is i moved to this
place and i was depressed and my mom a
week in l.a
lock myself in the room really it was
crazy what was your sandwich of choice i
think everyone wants to know turkey i
love a turkey
pepper jack
pepper jack a lot of chipotle so far
that's the first thing we have in common
yeah
we have a lot of things in common
so then
you call your mom my mom my mom would
call me she's lovely and she was just
like how you doing i'm like i'm fine i'm
just depressed and she was like i don't
want you to be depressed i heard about
something called imdb pro and i'm like
what is that mom
i saw you have a profile and some
person's name underneath it as your team
and she's like i'm just going to put my
email and like maybe you can go to
auditions and i was like rolling my eyes
she's a manager yeah but she wasn't at
the time
yeah she knew but she didn't know about
my mom i mean i've always been like you
know technology introducing my mom like
this is what happened so she had no idea
the fact that she knew it meant that she
did a
big effort
to make me happy which makes it even
sweeter
and she's like i'm gonna enroll you
sure
and so
she's like i you have an audition i got
an audition i was like cool
so then she's like you're gonna go i'm
like how long after i'm curious like a
week yeah and i'm like what is it for
and then by the way the way that they
audition america is completely different
to the way we audition we do chemistry
tests in mexico like that's all the type
of auditions we do oh that's always with
other people oh never like with you in a
random room on a camera great
occasionally like we should say
occasionally like that in america if you
get close enough to the job then you
start reading with the app but that's
how you do from the get-go
so you're always with an actor so i
never had read with someone like yeah
i'm so sad yeah
so i was so confused it was so
weird
i spoke english but not as well as i do
now it was all scary i had to memorize
english in my second language whatever
so i go
don't think much of it then i did
another and then they call me again and
they call me again and so
long story short i like had a couple
callbacks
and then eventually didn't get it and
then found out that the whole time i was
auditioning for star wars
no kidding the whole oh my god and i
wait which star wars what year was the
force awakens oh my god that's to me
seems like oh it was a couple years ago
so you know it was a long time ago it's
jesus
and i mean i'm not i want to make sure
to say for adam driver's part yes yeah i
was not like on the top nothing i was
just auditioning and it was fun and then
when i found out it was like for that i
was like oh my god that was crazy that
happened oh it makes sense that they
gave because that's what they did i'm
not telling you that i'm telling you
that they do that for like topsy really
like um top secret pride like star wars
they don't want this side they're very
and they don't tell you what it's for
script yeah yeah and so then i grabbed
my bags and went back to mexico and then
one day i didn't get star wars yeah i
didn't get star wars but it was fine i
was just like that was a great moment in
life and i will always remember it
goodbye going back to my country but did
you feel better at that but you felt
like you were now you gave me he gave me
some motive and yeah like give me drive
and i was like oh this is cool this
it just motivated me again which is what
my mom need was wanting to do yeah and
then one day i was in the middle of a
bridal shoot i will never forget i was
in the middle doing this cover for a
magazine as a bride it was weird now
that i think of it and then i get a
phone call i had a flip phone that i had
bought in like a 7-eleven
and uh
it rang and they're like hi this is uh
by the way a shout out to mary vernou oh
yeah mary vernou and i was like who
she's like i'm mary vernou mccaskill
character
who and she's like oh nice i was so oh
my god nice to meet you hi uh hi how are
you she's like hi
um
can you audition for this thing and
we'll send you sides but we need them
today wow well i got a stuff just for
just to let people know that mary vernou
is one of humongous biggest casting gave
me my break yeah i'd love her to die did
she get your number from imdb then i
don't know i'm probably wow i'm guessing
and that's why would that be whatever i
don't know but anyway she got the number
she called she sent the sides and then i
remember being in the bridal shoot and
then i asked the people from the shoot
if they could stop it for like 40
minutes and i had
i had gone in sweatpants so like i took
my makeup artist sure and then i had the
bridal dress underneath so they feel
like yeah it was so funny they framed it
up on like my face and i read off a page
i was like shake it right didn't have
time to memorize it so i read it and
then whatever tape it to take the
audition to take the audition so i was
reading off the page which i learned
briefly after i would never do again
yeah but anyway i did i sent it and then
the next day they're like oh can you
come fly into la there's this director
wants to audition you and it was robert
rodriguez did they tell you rodriguez on
the phone then yeah and do you know who
he was yeah of course yeah he was must
have been huge and so i was really
nervous or flew to l.a
then auditioned with zayn who was the
lead actor of the show and then the next
day
they're like robert wants to read you
again and then the other day he sent me
the picture of the first picture he ever
took of me i'll show it to you it's
crazy it's like a whole other person so
you're 20 at the time i'm like no i was
like 22 and now at this point and uh
he's like it's you you're moving it's
austin well let's go and that's how i'm
getting oh
and of all places i mean people are sick
at hearing me talk about how much i love
austin but oh what a great yeah and it
was the happiest years of my life i was
so happy it was my first job in english
ever i'd never worked in english
you told me the other day that i mean
we were talking to maggie she's gonna
hate that i said this and you were like
we were kind of teasing her about how
she says uh the s.a.w
it was just a surreal moment where he is
[Applause]
like what's the first thing that you
notice between shooting and oh my god
dude it's a whole different world that's
unbelievably different first of all i
was shooting 36 scenes to stay in mexico
so i'm on that track you know i'm like
used to like one take they don't do two
takes they don't
talk do you read teleport is it no no i
would memorize and i was like that's why
you're so good at it yeah i was like you
have a few because soap operas do use um
pieces the pieces which is by the way
like an earpiece
they tell you the lines in your ear to
repeat them which is crazy i don't know
i did a hosting job once where i did
that and was like yeah it's really weird
it just gives you like it gave me a
dissociate yeah like when i'm speaking i
would i would we can't be president is
wrong it's really weird yeah but um wow
so we would do
today i worked 12 months a year wow oh
yeah that's right no vacations one day
off like seven days a week uh-huh there
aren't there's we have yeah it's sag and
after really there's strong unions
they're good unions so we have i talked
to a japanese actor friend of mine who
said i just took it took it for granted
that we have these there are these
regulations in place and like um
it must have been a welcome change it
must have been nice for you it was so
nice and then it was also like scary
because it kind of raised the stakes
because it's like oh yes oh so we're
zeroed into one thing so performance
really matters so then i i remember like
i look back at some of that stuff is so
bad it's like i'm so over acting
over pronunciating words because i'm so
so so nervous of like not sounding
american and i felt like i had to it was
like a lot of lessons learned right
were you playing a
lot you were playing a
latino character yeah but i i spoke
mostly in english oh so i had some lines
in spanish but it was mostly in english
we should tell you just uh it's from
dusk till dawn yeah and and if you
haven't seen the movie yes salma hayek
plays a
an exotic dance exotic dancer who then
turns into spoiler alert a um a vampire
but but so she danced with i remember
this you know everyone remembers
everything every hot blooded american
boy remembers the talk about trying to
like live up to that oh yes this is an
iconic scene where she's dancing with
the snake i didn't live up to it i i'm
so easy i can accept it fully which is
fine i tried my best i was so lucky that
that was my introduction to i've heard
you know some horror stories and mine
was the opposite i had the best director
i love robert like robert directed all
the episodes he was the show runner he
no he was the creator producer and he
directed most episodes and then i want
to see that show
i mean
yeah i'd be into it
i was terrible i was really bad when you
say what how would you describe that
well because it's crazy to see like
you've auditioned with me you've helped
me with the couples you're great and
natural but i remember i say that only
because i look back at some of the stuff
i did early on like even stuff that
people would keep watching which is
painful around like horror movies that
all right and i see them like well i
cringe because i i
just
add to that they're like secondly second
language and like learning how it works
in america and i was coming off of soap
operas so it was like a little bit too
much i was pushing way too far you were
waiting for the like that that's
happening yes
so cringe that was really cringe well
how would robert direct you then from
from breaking those how would he help
you break those excuses because he would
just be very cool about it he wouldn't
make me feel uncomfortable you would
just be like yeah try this and then i
would be like sure and and the the
attitude was everything that helped me
more casually and then you know i i just
he
he was very helpful to start finding
myself as an actress and
then sure enough right after that i did
baby driver which was what really you
know did the yes that's right edgar
wright it's um if you haven't seen it
obviously he's a great director so he
saw you in
destadon it was a similar he did he's
friends with robert he's friends with us
uh robert yeah i auditioned and i did
the audition process and it was crazy
and i never never thought i was going to
get it i thought she looked so much
bigger than me oh cause it was such big
names already
oh my god but i love edgar because man
he
that like between edgar and robert i
will
anything what is he like as a director
he seems so specific to me he's so he's
so clear
i love that he's like super type a like
he had clear ideas shot by shot and
beat pipes
i mean we've talked about this multiple
times in interviews about baby driver
but he sent us the script and the
playlist at the same time and it played
while you were reading it so it was
insane so was we could see exactly what
was going on and it was really cool it
was really cool oh so he cut all of that
that makes sense to the songs he already
knew what song yeah
yeah
he wrote the script based on the songs
that is yeah i got to see i want to see
that movie again
especially now knowing you a little bit
because you're so you know i was it was
strange meeting you because my
perception of you i i guess had been
from that which is like
real like
yeah
yeah you were saying and then
subsequently you did a lot of um
big action movies and like
hobbs and
john
you must know when people come up like
oh where they know you from yeah totally
i do i mean it's very specific audiences
yes
but yeah i mean
i'm so grateful of everything that i've
done
and by the way from destin was great i
was i was just bad in it but man the
last three four years have been so
eye-opening and you know a bunch of my
stories and like it really changed my
perspective of like i don't have to act
like i'm happy to be here anymore like
i can own the place that i am and i can
own
wanting better stuff and yeah requiring
requesting for
better things for women and better
things for latin women with all these
changes that everyone knows about like
seismic changes that are happening now
what does that mean for a latin actress
actually oh my god well i also like what
are you hoping for well i went through
the whole
me too movement and then like time's up
and
uh women empowering movement like it
happened while
when i got here into now it's like 360
for the women in the industry right it
was that time it was that time and i saw
the dark side and i saw the light and
and it's kind of like
i'm glad that i was on the other side of
when it wasn't great yet because it also
makes you grateful of now how better
it's gotten but i also feel like there's
miles to go for specifically latin women
i mean
it's brutal man like you and i were
talking about it the other day that i
hope that what's happening with the
with the black lives matter movement and
it creates more consciousness about
minorities and i feel like a minority
that gets very overlooked it's a latino
and
i do think the latina women just fall
into this category of like
[ __ ]
or
or hot piece or the help
and drug dealer it's like
those four and
for me it's like when do we become
ironically contemporary yeah yeah when
do you play when is it just like you're
the right actress and that's where it
becomes tricky because when it comes to
like when i read for roles that are not
background specific then you're
competing with everybody and then
obviously there's different likes and
different trends and different moments
and i do feel like we consistently get
maybe i'm being a downer but i do feel
like we get pushed down and like
something that comes up in the running
that is like a little bit more glitz and
glamorous and but it usually never
it rarely is our turn
rarely is and i'm talking specifically
latina yeah you would say yeah that
makes sense now that i've seen
that i'm sure you go up for a lot of
those parts or you did go out for a lot
of parts that were like the badass the
the would you say that the um
i forget what's the saturating
stereotype and the spicy the scent is
spicy hard and then especially when you
break into the industry with that kind
of role yeah because then it's like well
that you are perpetuating there's this
all this right
am i perpetuating or like or do i just
not work i want to work i wanted to work
and then what we were talking about the
other day is like things have gotten
very heightened to bring awareness of
things and then sometimes the pendulum
swings way too far one side went too far
the other this is the thing i didn't go
into acting to always be mexican i don't
want to do a dna test i
became i wanted to be a princess and an
astronaut in like a medieval times
whatever
so my whole point being is like it's
fine i i just think
let's just let everyone play everything
how about that and obviously not the
obvious the obvious things like if
you're making a biopic of someone yeah
you're not you should respect you're not
playing andre the giant yes exactly
unfortunately great part but or you know
what i mean but if there is room
for someone to do that then there should
be room for me
to
play well that's the thing what is that
when you talk about the pendulum what is
that middle ground for latino women you
said all those other stereotypes that
latin women are often cast as is it
important for you to avoid like make a
deliberate move to like not play those
parts
i mean yeah it has and then you work
less you know because i went through
like identity crisis through a bit last
few years because i was caught in
between a couple of projects were like
pulling from both sides which was like
you have to be this you're not good yeah
and the other one was like
the ultimate whitewashing and so i was
like what is happening like
what is the middle ground the arts have
become so politically correct yeah and
as they should but
people that are trying to be politically
correct don't know how to be politically
correct so they're creating all this
within the industry because we haven't
settled on the rules yet yeah because
also i feel like for the audience they
just see the outcome they don't know
what's happening in the inside and
that's where i feel like it's the dark
side that is still being perfected
[Music]
this is something that hadn't occurred
to me we're in this podcast room is in a
very white
town it's in a we i live in the town of
connecticut that's very white and you
don't and i'm trying to see this town a
little bit more through your lens just
being around you last few days and and
it occurred to me we were like at the be
everyone was white and everyone was like
and you said something interesting that
was um but there are degrees then of
looking i'm just superficially being
latin and i'm sure in mexico you telling
stories about growing from mexico there
are there were more native looking
people and so there are i spent time in
central america there are hierarchies
there they're always going to be these
oh yeah so where do you exist in the
spectrum of latin women it's really
interesting because i am considered
depending from who is looking at me
right i'm
from latinos to latinos i am a white
latina americans i'm not just a latina
like it just depends like everyone has
an opinion and it's really weird when
you're right when we're in a world where
like don't be judged by the color of
your skin but you're being judged by the
color of yourself of course and it's
like it is really interesting but then
there is moments where like you know
i've seen projects where like
they were like we just choose the right
person for the job they said something
really interesting this year like we
don't see colors and we don't see and
uh i said can i give you my opinion on
the statement that you just said i don't
want to be disrespectful or overstepping
he's like sure and i was like that is
not so valid because if you're judging
it based on jobs and someone that is
quote unquote right for the job you're
basing it off of their what you've seen
of them right so if you've seen of
someone
like let's say and a white actress that
has had 45 other movies because she's
been allowed to play all these things
and i've only had a certain amount then
obviously if i was from your side i'd be
like she's better because i've seen her
do this
but you haven't seen me and so it's not
a it's not a it's not a fair start-up
point because we're not starting we're
there's a disadvantage there's a massive
disadvantage of course and that is a
that's such a
that's a very privileged fancy example
of
the systemic oppression and
marginalization that's happened in our
in this country for you know yeah and
that's why i feel like it's
controversial to talk about
all these rules that they're like
stipulating on the industry and like
what can be
submitted for awards but i think
at the end of the day
that example that i just applied applies
for films too like
i told you earlier today that this year
no latino was nominated for any emmy
zero nada na da if you do your digging
there's some incredible latin shows if
we don't put more latin actors leading
movies leading shows then it's never
going to be
normal you got to normalize it you got
it and then sometimes you've got to
force people into doing it and it's not
getting a leg in or like whatever what's
the say it's like a leg up thank you
it's not a leg up it's just giving
someone has been
given the disadvantage forever to
actually prove themselves if he's not
worthy let him go yeah it's true you
gotta allow people and and that's going
to require time time to you need people
opportunities to catch up now i'm
looking for stories that i can produce
that'd be not even i i don't necessarily
want to star in most of them i just want
to create for other actors other actors
female directors to come in from latin
america direct i want to start creating
opportunity because
i can say for me at least i i lacked
mentorship when i moved here and i
didn't really have any woman mentoring
me at all and i i don't want i want to
be able to do that for other people and
the way that has the the industry has
designed it and i don't blame them
because the way that this industry has
assigned it it makes us
consistently compete with each other so
how are you gonna ask humans that are
like consistently competing like against
the same
two three two three two three for like
for the
bare minimum you know like for the bones
we're like
you came to this country to hollywood
during like the most seismic changes how
has it gotten better for
latin actresses and latin women oh it's
been good because i feel like i don't
have to feel guilty to take up space
like i don't like i feel
comfortable
speaking up and people
have learned i can have ideas and feel
secure and sure about my idea being
listened to and being heard being hurt
being hurt and creating and being
excited about being creative and like
making
unexpected turns and
and it's it's changed you know it really
has changed and people
that's the one thing i'll say about
social media and like the internet that
is beautiful the one only thing i think
is how it's cross borders it's allowed
for people to like
know that there's different worlds and
that you have to appeal to different
people and to really understand
different audiences because one thing is
like a review of a paper that comes to
someone's office it says these are the
numbers in
china or latin america or whatever and
then a whole other thing is seeing the
actual physical videos actions
posts like the currency that is
happening in those countries so
you do it did change because people
became way more aware of how important
it is to globalize and what's being put
like on film totally and there's more
transparency across the board
transparency from something like this
what we're talking about to something
really grim and and obviously more with
higher stakes like police brutality and
people are filming these things now it's
not like
it's happening for the first time or
there's like a rash of these incidents
it's just being captured yeah it's being
shared and um okay sorry i could do that
i could talk to y'all but we should get
we should uh wrap it up what is your
most commonly used emoji
i hate him i'm not you're not really
hate emojis um you never use them
i do but i i you know the people that
send a lot of emojis
um
my most commonly emotional crying
laughing because i feel like it really
embodies my cackle yeah the one that is
not the like
one but the sideways
yeah
we went to a bill burr show a former
guest of the show yeah um and you're a
lot of cackling from he was very happy
okay from you you are attacking a lot of
tackling for me uh if you could be a
professional athlete what sport would
you play basketball uh-huh
the lakers fan oh it's clippers
none no that's i was at miami heat when
we had him there and then went
m.i.a from them for a minute and then i
was a golden state warrior for a fan fan
for oh because of our mutual friend yeah
elsa yeah did you go to the games with
elsa or yeah i did that
she
because our friend elsa's husband works
for the warriors so we went a couple of
times yeah i did it was really fun she's
great by the way shout out to elsa uh
who runs uh an organization this is how
we met this is how he met and this is
called this is about humanity
great organization they um they do a lot
of work at the border and these uh
detention centers that are unfortunately
popping up left and right um
so we went to tijuana there check them
out uh this is about ximena and yes we
can which is they work with um an
amazing woman who who came from l.a
created these uh schools
from buses really check it out yes
weekend and it's about humanity okay uh
and you're a cowboys fan cowboys fans
yeah uh how are they doing this year
we had a really good game the other day
hopefully i mean we were i'm putting all
my you know ziki and dak and we got we
got we got we hope for the bus it's so
funny those are such like cutesy names
but they're such like hiziki
oh my god i never thought of that by the
way i never said that to their faces
never or never i just be like you guys
are good great game uh if you could have
one snack food for the rest of your life
oh
that's a hard one um
i'm i'm more of like a food person i
don't like snacks i'm not a snacky
person okay but i do love the kettle the
kettle vinegar salt you sure do love
them yeah okay that's a good kettle
something you're okay so bloated but i
would eat them every day yeah oh salt uh
what's your favorite movie of all time
oh
wow that's hard i know
i don't have one or like like um
let me rephrase a movie that brings you
you're kind of down you want to just veg
out you want comfort you want to be like
comforted like wrap up in a blanket and
hang out with a friend i mean that kind
of movie it's always the notebook oh
okay that's like the romantic in me but
my favorite movie by the way that's just
it's a great i know people tease the
notebook it's such a good it's so good
they're both incredible
incredible so
they're so captivating yeah it's so
captivating there's something so magical
about her specifically in that movie
she's also so good in uh i love working
with that audition tape for her in that
movie oh my i always watch it i'm
obsessed she just
radiates like she has control but
endearingness and i love her i'm in love
with her wow good audition tape is to
beat that i i love steve carell's oh the
office it's so good when he's laughing
sorry no in in anchorman oh my gosh
watch his audition tape for anchorman is
it the one that he's laughing so hard
if you could have dinner with three
people dead or alive whom you've never
met
that i've never met yeah or that you met
like very superficially and like i
really want to get to work three people
dead or alive
oh my god this is a hard one this is
definitely not a lightning round of
questions
we come back to it yes how about this
back to that one uh if you had to live
somewhere else where would it be hawaii
uh-huh hawaii oh man i hope you yeah uh
who was your favorite muppet
i hated the muppets oh really
i don't like that you know what you
hated them i understand not watching
them but
i lied i actually lied i'm i fully lied
i had one job when i was three years old
i booked sesame street okay i swear and
i got kicked and i got fired
sesame street plaza
and then i got fired and uh then from
there on i grew hating anything that was
like plasticized
muppets oh no wonder you so you actually
do hate them i hate them yeah like uh i
don't know you're like gossiping i was
three years old but i was already saying
[ __ ] you
oh my god
you kicked me out of the job no i'm
kidding i'm totally kidding yeah it's so
jaded by the way i know already such a
way how did you break it you were just
horsing around with it you're three
being me
um okay well i'm sorry i asked that
question if you had to be one age for
the rest of your life
you know what would it be knowing what
you know you have your intellect i
wouldn't want to be younger anymore like
i look back i'm like
this is a tough question to ask you like
obviously you ask older people that it's
like ooh 30 or 27 i think you are that
80 i think yeah 20
no 28 28 was a great age um if you could
be reincarnated as a non-human animal
what would you want to be oh my like
what do you identify with as in again
when you see an animal and you're like i
feel kind of like it's my spirit horse a
horse yeah it could be a horse like
freight
yeah maine like flying you know it's
funny they're postcards downstairs i was
going to tell you about this um from a
place called cumberland island have you
ever heard of cumberland yeah it's off
the coast of savannah yeah yeah and it's
the most incredible i think it's in that
book thousand places to go before you
die but it's an island where all these
rich people
in the early 20th century had like the
rockefellers had homes there and then
after the market crashed in the 20s they
all left they abandoned them so there's
these like old ruins of like you know
pillars beautiful and then there's one
place that they converted they
refurbished and turned into like a bed
and breakfast and you can stay there and
there's
wild horses there was an accident there
was a
shipwreck and these horses washed up on
the
so cool so you just you would love it
you gotta go cumberland island okay
horses wow so funny you don't
don't look like a horse uh which would
you rather be called unattractive or
unfunny
oh my god i'm 100 unattractive ah yeah
i'd rather be funny all day yeah it's
awesome am i funny though
no i'm going to let the audience do that
yes i don't know i don't think i've been
really honest
podcasts have been very deep and serious
what's good yeah yeah but i i i consider
myself funny you're funny uh yeah um
no you're funny you're funny a hundred
percent i'm funny right uh i'm funny
yeah in fact i remember that day that we
uh we hang out with this is about
humanity um and we played heads up we
played we i left we just laughed so much
right back how long was that right from
tijuana two hours
yeah that was longer it felt like no two
hours um which did you ever watch the
golden girls in mexico do they have the
golden girls no okay what american
sitcoms made it to mexico friends oh
yeah okay
did seinfeld seinfeld fully made it
really yeah cheers did you oh okay
and who would you be on so you watched
any of those growing up uh yeah um
who would you be who would you play on
cheers
let's say oh guy or girl i don't know i
don't remember much of cheers because my
dad would watch it i was really young
like did i continue to watch
we wasn't leslie jordan in
uh will and grace yes yes yes sir just
remember this i was like wait i 100 seen
this man who's trending on social media
before former life is short guess yeah
let's hear your leslie jordan well [ __ ]
what are y'all doing
growing up
i don't know if it's great it's pretty
good what are y'all doing
i do with that all the time with my
friends you do i know i heard you do
that the other day well [ __ ] well well
she is well she what are y'all doing i
like that he adds extra syllables i love
that
yeah
yeah hello uh no i can't think of it
it's just a word um dogs or cats do you
prefer dogs uh-huh you have two great
cat lady uh-huh
you're like snarling yeah
the beatles were the rolling stones oh
the rolling stones oh yeah huh i know
i'm telling you it was a little more
rock yeah did you ever see them
no i didn't and i was going to they had
that concert in california
um
and then they did like a reunion didn't
they they're always touring i don't
think they needed to do it they didn't
know but like
they did what was it called it was
actually they think it did happen it was
like a really insane like biggest con
like a biggest old-school rock band like
a
and it was a random place not like
coachella was like a random place in
california i don't remember i will look
it up but i wanted to go and didn't but
i do love the rolling stones i have seen
the rolling stones like what am i
talking about i have seen them uh
they went to mexico oh yeah i did
chocolate candy fruity candy you're not
a big sweet chocolate just chocolate
would you ever think about um
your legacy the um how you want to be
remembered
no
scary yeah that is so scary to think of
do you think that especially to end this
show that way who would do that who does
that justin morbid uh no legacy no
career-wise no but i think about
your people leaving the earth yeah i
think of that i like i i find myself a
very caring friend i do think of me as
like
ultimately caring friend like i check on
my friends consistently and i'm always
like thinking of them
especially when they really need it i
think i'm like a resource a resourceful
friend for when it's actually
required but i would like to be thought
of some friend that loves to listen and
care for the loved ones that she has
because i love my friends well and your
friends seem to really love you i i pay
them to say that oh okay wow
so you need to get a job now to
maintain your friendships you're the
other day you're like you have a lot of
friends a lot of us like well also i
have like
my friend said that my friend betty said
uh she's not very good at why is the
best phrasing uh watering relationship
she has a hard time watering
relationships and that's very you're
good at you i became good at it because
i wasn't good at it and i knew that in
porn it was important because then it
takes time off of being
involved with yourself yes so it allows
you to be involved with others i think
that the greatest gift i've learned is
like
the more that i allow myself to be
involved with others is the more i've
grown in my entire life versus when i
was like introspective and being me and
learning of course
yeah you just it's that's also boring
it's not as interesting circles yeah
well that's why
i love doing this and that's why i've
i've really loved getting to know you
and uh
i'm your friend i've watered this
friendship yes oh we've been drowning in
the last couple of days yeah you're
gonna need it we've had like hardcore
hangouts yeah
we've done a lot of stuff i love how you
say his name bilber bill burr
but wilbur well his number his name is
wilbur wilfred wilfred that's that's
right wilbur yeah i'm gonna try to see
bill um
um he
is the best you're the best thanks for
joining us thank you it's fun
um okay and and uh
plugging oh what's coming out
what is coming out we have a movie
that is probably oh yeah
yeah i went to tift did pretty well
called i care a lot with uh roseman pike
and peter dinklage and chris messina and
the lovely diane wiese directed by jane
blakeson beautiful movie i you will
probably have it sooner than later in
your tvs okay and then
uh i have king kong versus godzilla
coming out next year which is exciting i
just got very like i didn't know you did
that
king kong versus godzilla yes sir shh
where'd you shoot that i shot in hawaii
and australia amazing the best i had so
much fun so who wins i can't okay all
right well you're gonna have to yeah
so you play which one king godzilla i am
god's
so you are stretching there are
opportunities really really like diving
into new opportunities actually i can
see that um yeah uh well i i can't wait
to see it yeah i hope you like it and
even if i don't i'll tell you i do
because you paid me to be yes i paid you
handsomely uh
all right well thank you thank you bye
guys
knew how to say that in spanish now that
well that happened yeah you know what
i'm gonna look yeah it was a fun listen
was it it must have been because you've
been around her you had been around her
uh must have been like oh it's my buddy
my new buddy i didn't know that about
her dad that's really sad that he he
died when she was a kid oh you hadn't
heard that yeah um when she was you know
12 at a very formative time right and
she
i didn't know if she was going to speak
about that because she had been telling
me about that the night before and
obviously it's very personal and
sensitive and but yeah she seems very
forthcoming about uh oh she's she's
outspoken and
bueno eso paso
well that just happened well
i think well that happened as a more uh
colloquial yeah
but if you were to colloquial in spanish
okay hold on
all right sir uh yeah bueno eso paso
see i
also my accent my my like i have no she
is such a great she just speaks so it's
so fun to hear her speak isn't it you're
so like impressed by her ability to
speak spanish well because she's facing
but it's her language oh colloquial is
just colloquial
but she's also uh her grasp of english
is like that's her second language and
then i read
uh she also speaks italian
and some french to me that's really
impressive here's uh even extra
impressive is the fact that she didn't
mention that every time she said
something um
like a spanish name or a spanish phrase
you would repeat it under your breath
and it made me laugh so hard at one
point i wrote it down she said um she
said i think his name is
pedro
or something and you just go peter
you can't help yourself yeah it's i
what is that what does that mean it's
like kristen bell has that we talked
about that it's like a form of like
like accent tourette's or something i
don't know what it not to be not to be
little people like tourette's no problem
that's offensive yeah sorry uh i know
you're not supposed to say this anymore
um no
wait
i i think i can't wait sensitive i think
it's another one of those defensive
things uh but
she said it about herself so i can say
it she said she has masculine energy
and i think she does i think she's right
and i know i know you're not supposed to
say that because you know
gender is construct and what does it
mean to have masculine energy or
feminine energy if she had heard of the
golden girls let's say uh she hadn't
heard of the golden girls uh-huh because
they didn't have it when she grew up
uh-huh uh i would say pretty clearly
she's a blanche
yes you know
yeah she's body she's got a little
she's got a little um dorothy yeah
i wonder where that comes from she's
like a good time kind of body
what does that mean golden girls
i judged her i prejudged her a little
bit um because of her beauty no because
because she's you know in movies and
she's an actress and a lot of actresses
i know
you know sometimes they have a little
precious little like princess yeah
behavior i'll tell you this
by the way
i was gonna say i'm not staying in
twenty two dollar night motels anymore
right i've gotten you so
i expected her to be a little like oh
really the comedy show is outside on the
grass we have to like sit on the ground
yeah she was um
not at all precious about she's down her
comfort or lacked their eye
that was pretty cool i and i
i she proved me wrong i i should not
have
prejudged her yeah you don't know yeah i
don't know i don't know yeah she i
that's a really that's a really charming
combination you know somebody who uh
who can just
rough it a little bit rough it a little
bit yeah and i i i witnessed some of
that when we went to tijuana um that day
and she was right in the mix with i have
to say i was there was um this is
pre-covered uh so
if you can remember that far back uh but
there was an outbreak some of the kids
were sick with something there was a
cold at one of the stops that we made
and
i i remember being quite squeamish and
like not wanting to get too close to
some of the kids like oh i don't want to
get sick and she was right there in the
mix she was hugging because by the way
all of the kids down there
in tijuana they all grew and they were
mostly central americans they were in
tijuana but they were mostly hondurans
and salvadorians fleeing uh there were
refugees um who had been fleeing
violence and these kids so they'd gone
through a lot and it was i'm gonna cry
thinking about it it was so
beautiful to see their reaction to her
and how she just put herself right in
the mix of these kids and and uh they
got so excited by her presence because
she is as she talks about down there
huge um yeah i had seen her in baby
driver and was like yeah you know she's
on some things but they just loved her
hey let's read a letter okay i emailed
it to you because our printer is broken
oh also first guest who hates the
muppets oh oh does she hate them hates
no but then she picked one right no she
hates them she does yeah she because she
got fired from oh yeah that's right
she's like bitter against the muppet
we've had guests who didn't know the
muppets i don't think wolfgang puck knew
the muppets yeah
but uh
i've never heard of anyone hey i didn't
know it's possible to hate the muppets
by the way i would think if you had just
told me that about her i would held that
against i would have thought i'm not
going to get along with somebody who
hates the muppets i know yeah and i
think nothing less of her if anything
i'd like her more for admitting that
it's like it's funny it's like hating
christmas or something
how do you hit
well
she explains how i know very honest
about it
this is from weird mark gonzalez
huh
uh subject love the podcast theater
relevance and some would you rather's
hello this is great all three of those
things hello long brothers my name is
mark gonzalez sending you love from hazy
smoky fresno california oh boy
i've been listening to the podcast since
episode one thanks mark and it's been a
weekly staple of my weekly enjoyments
that's awesome the banter the humor the
quarantine realness the everything has
been a much needed breath of fresh air
literally for me oh man listening to
your podcast along with my own humor
makes me feel like the three of us are
at a bar drinking something other than
light beers and shooting the [ __ ] maybe
but like seltzer yeah
yeah you know what's funny that bud
light seltzer keeps coming up even
though we don't have to do it
we never had to do it that's true we got
to do it dad that's a good thing
correction um i am back to mark i am a
high school isn't that weird that's the
gonzales yeah well i think it's a very
common name oh it it in latin america
but he's writing from fresno yeah
california a lot of uh former latin
american descendants this is true former
that's redundant
uh i'm a high school theater teacher oh
cool currently in my second year and
it's been quite quite crazy with digital
teaching as you can imagine yeah how do
they do that how do you do a play
how do you because you have to like
plays aren't happening professional
plays but well they are i guess they're
doing like zoom zoom stuff yeah
um
however back to mark however my students
are in good spirits i have the advantage
of teaching for my classroom and theater
oh wow so it's as good as it can be
within the confines of cobin 19. your
podcast is one i often find myself
telling my students about ah thanks mark
because they love the guests you
interview and the jokes are endless
listening to the nathan lane episode was
literally in my wheelhouse
hmm
is there a wheel you must have a
wheelhouse yeah
what's the wheelhouse
is that a house is that you don't pull
that to not know what a wheelhouse is
is that a place where you keep wheels i
would assume
uh i guess we'll find out oh boy those
kids aren't going to laugh at that
um that's cool that that his students
some of his students maybe or they were
i want to know what a wheelhouse is yeah
me too you don't have to be curious
about what a actual warehouse is i had
the great pleasure of seeing nathan oh
okay he's gonna describe
i had the great pleasure of seeing
nathan lane in the nance on broadway it
was also the show where i got to meet
him and get his autograph on the jacket
cover of the producers cast recording oh
cool thus making me quite happy
i have a theater review blog
the road to 1000 not a sponsor
nice
uh and in it i reviewed the actor who
played ned the role i assumed you read
for that is the role i read for i
actually read the part why did i assume
is it like the nerdy guy with bushy
eyebrows yeah it's the part yeah
it's other like it's not the ace of
gonzalez part right and in it i reviewed
the actor who played ned the role i
assume you read for as quote showing us
that at least he memorized his lines
oh wait that was his review of that
actor
yeah
well that's not and i just read it
that's
that's so it's not good
i can only imagine how fully realized
you would have delivered that character
had you played it it may have even
become an iconic performance one might
say
you know that's interesting because
that's such a complimentary thing to say
thank you mark um he's [ __ ] on someone
else to compliment you yeah and yet i
feel bad for i hope that whoever did
play that part is not listening and even
if he is people get bad reviews it's
okay i know but i know how bad it feels
to get a better view i i have such a
thin skin with that but i
appreciate the the hypothetical good
review
i don't know um now i'm curious who
played that part okay back to his letter
okay i'm sure christian is over me
boosting your ego oh yeah whoa good call
mark
so let's get to some would you rather
he really has been listening
yeah he knows you're interested in
people like if you listen enough you
probably do a pretty good uh dissection
of someone's personality psychological
profile scary it is and cool i mean it's
cool
yeah
maybe you knew we were gonna say that oh
god
okay so back to the letter um number one
would you rather speak without
pronouncing vowels for the rest of your
life
or every third word you say is dropped
from the conversation this includes
writing and sign language wow so that
would be
okay i i i'd be too hard for me to speak
without vowels pronouncing vowels for
the rest of my life and every i i'd have
to get used to every third word i would
have to just add
like insignificant
words every third word i would have to
develop a new way of speaking like you
can't do that
in this type of i would have to drop
this i would raspberry have to no see i
to me blueberry for the sake i disagree
okay so this is his example
would normally be
hello mom i love you
versus hello mom
love you
well that's different because that's
such a simple lucky you stop the eye
yeah but so it's
uh here's why it sounds like you're
peanut butter in your mouth right like
exactly well this is why i disagree
because it's annoying it'll be annoying
to do and listen to
but you would still make sense to people
like
it would be difficult sometimes to
understand some of the words you were
saying for sure but you could still
communicate whereas if you dropped the
third word
of everything you said
you would run into some serious
difficulty uh explaining yourself to
people people would be really confused
by what by what you were saying like you
wouldn't be able to uh be clear i'm
going to say you really would have a
hard time with that
you really i'm going to say you really
need a sentence you really would have a
hard time communicating read a sentence
that he wrote and drop the third letter
of each word okay should i read the full
sentence first
yeah okay i had the great pleasure of
seeing nathan lane and the nance on
broadway so it'd be
i had
great pleasure
seeing nathan
in the
on broadway
see exactly so in this it'd be
impossible
would be completely lost because you did
you wouldn't know what he saw
well then wouldn't you just
couldn't you in this hypothetical ad
like
i had you add like you can't can't
that's the whole point you have to drop
third i would definitely use the volume
i guess so i guess you're right and
people would just have to get used to
like like asa would have to know that
when you say
s
you're
you're saying her name right
yeah
if you were saying to asa i love you
how would you say will you marry me
murray
yeah
hmm
ironies you sound like a muppet and
she'd probably turn be turned off it's
not the only way
that's a really good point okay
um
good one i mean scary but that really
triggered me yeah you got really upset
yes i don't like that okay number two uh
would you rather kick a soccer ball with
a toothpick between your big toe
and the big toenail oh
you're kicking with i just got shivers
oh oh god oh jesus mark these are great
or biting down on a nail file
oh boy and having it ripped from your
mouth b b
nail file i'd rather do that as awful as
that sounds
this occurrence happens once a month for
the rest of your life i'm sweating you
are you're flushed you look like you you
have uh
you look like you you ate shellfish um
christian breaks out and hot like
splotches on his face we call it
shellfish face okay okay now now mark's
gonna know that about you too well mark
is also about to find out that um i have
a real problem with
like nails like crazy flipping your
nails too short and that feeling of
pinching your that
can we stop talking about it yeah yeah
but i like is there another one i can't
believe we haven't talked about this is
that you don't like christian hates this
ah i'm rubbing my hands together like a
um like a cartoon villain
or like and christian oh i can't believe
we've never talked about that it's like
worse than nails on a chalkboard to me
can we it's like i'm sweating you are
you you is that all of them it's just a
little hot in here there's one more can
you wait i can't wait
this is great
number three have to wear shoes on the
wrong foot for the rest of your life
same rule for flip-flops crocs boots
frogs cracks he knew to add crocs
uh or
never have sunglasses on a sunny day
oh
sunglasses i'm not a big sunglasses guy
yeah in fact i don't really like seeing
the world through sunglasses especially
now that we're wearing masks everywhere
because i i feel like i look like the
invisible man with a pair of sunglasses
and that big because i've been wearing
you know obviously wear masks um oh yeah
i would ditch the sunglasses
that's easy for me it's like me too i
would do sunglasses if i got to keep
like skittles or something i'm really
not into something oh really yeah i
could really take them or leave them uh
i would rather sunglasses than skittles
i i i haven't had i haven't used
skittles i haven't found value in
skittles i would say in the last six
months whereas i've worn funny did i
tell you this the other day i was
driving around and i'm a skill i had a
hankering for skittles so i i stopped
off the cvs and i bought a i haven't
done this in
years i haven't had skittles in a long
time oh my god you you and i love
skittles if you weren't just different
than asa gonzalez you like you really
went over the top so i went to uh cvs
because i had this overwhelming urge to
have skills and i bought i went there
just to buy a bag of skittles yeah and i
ate them all in the car and what yeah i
felt like menopausal or something
i never have cravings like that for you
what are you breaking isn't that weird
and did you eat them all in one sitting
yeah you finished the ba how big a bag
did you get a normal bag that's awesome
but you know here's the problem with
skittles now
they the green is no longer lemon lime
rather i prefer the apple oh you're
wrong
wrong no no here's why we've had this
discussion it throws off the whole [ __ ]
it's you know what it throws off the
whole balance not to me because the lime
complemented the other flavors so much
better the green apple sticks out like a
sore thumb here's my argument for green
apple you have such an unrefined palette
i don't know i don't taste that
seriously you know can we get some
letters about this
please write in uh life is short at
wondering.com uh and weigh in on this
this very controversial topic
here's my argument the lime was too
close to the lemon uh
wrong it was here's here's the argument
that's different than lemon of course it
is combine them give me a lemon lime but
don't give me a lemon
there are so many lemon lime flavored
things because because exactly they
combine them no they complement each
other well but they're not the same
flavor they're in the same ballpark
they're in the same neighborhood they're
in the same neighborhood no no way too
close they live they should be living
together that's why they combine them
here's that's why sprite and slice and
mountain do all that all those flavors
plenty of things like i'm in line
because they're complementary not
because they're similar oil and vinegar
grapes strawberries oil and vinegar are
combined banana strawberry is combined
they're very difficult it shouldn't be
those are two different benefits that's
why skittles that's banana strawberry go
together like peas and carrots peas and
carrots
peas and carrots are combined yeah but
you wouldn't combine them into a single
thing into a single flavor you would
like a medley yeah that's the nice thing
about skittles is that you can do those
combinations on your own you can that's
what i like about it you can curate your
own combination exactly right which is
why if you take green apple or lime just
like one on one i can see the argument
for the green apple i i wouldn't agree
with that but
but for the full if you just grab it and
i just get older i just realized
something i think the green apple throws
off the balance i just realized a
handful of skittles here's what we're
discovering here's the truth we eat
skittles differently right you are you
will combine you go flavored by flavors
yeah
i like flavor by flavor what are you
seven years old yeah i like flavor by
flavor do you lay them all out and put
them in different little piles no but i
do um i like to because i like to say
best for last especially with like any
sort of meal like if i get uh well i
agree with that like a three
you know both are just the best for
lasting meal uh like in the in the three
we've been eating that sushi great by
the way shout out to shikihana in
fairfield connecticut great sushi place
and uh you know and i'll get a
california roll a salmon roll and a
yellow you save your last bite your
favorite i just imagine like asa and her
friends were like listening to this
episode because she's on it and they've
like definitely turned it off
by the way what's what's your order i
mean i think let me guess your order
wait in the new order of green apples
green okay uh and if i mean i'm going
individual let's go okay let's go number
one best to least okay you mean least to
best what you eat first yeah okay fine
wait wait right on the count of three
why are we doing a count of three i
don't know you trust me all right you're
right all right my first that i'm eating
is lemon
me too yeah and then i'm going you don't
both have to think lemon is the worst
skittles flavor and then i'm going to go
green apple and then i'll go orange okay
i'll go orange and then i'll go grape
and then i'll finish with strawberries
i knew that but it's still
amazing what grape's your favorite yes i
like rape a lot but i prefer red really
buy a little bit wow i think they're
close but i prefer red i'm gonna i'm
gonna go yellow
now orange
used to be yellow green do you like the
green apple i like the green apple well
and then i'll go green and then red
all right this is riveting uh is that
the end of the letter
no he says
he says thanks for the good work guys
and i can't wait for the next episode
stay safe sincerely mark and awesome
thank you
really nice and um
awesome good would you rather some
triggering oh yeah you're still like a
little bit broken out so thank you to
mark and thank you to the very cool
uh asap
would like to write in uh justin said it
earlier but i will repeat it the email
address is life is short at
wondery.com
and we really appreciate all of you
listening and we'll talk to you next
week okay gracias life could be a dream
life could be a dream
a life short is hosted by me justin long
it is produced and hosted co-hosted by
christian long and megan monaco your
producers michelle me lans audio
engineer is sergio enriquez it's
executive produced by two men two men
named neymar
marshall louie and hernan lopez for
wondering
[Music]
since looks were fleeting
yeah and some really nice ones because
damian was saying oh look in the box
there's some pictures beautiful grandma
was and blah blah blah so and you'll see
my high school graduation dress that i
designed
really the lady next door made it for me
oh i'd like to see that what do you like
it did you was it pretty and i i lent it
to lou
when there was a contest of the archaeol
palace
like a cross dressing oh it was there no
losers
sure so we fixed it she had a smaller
waist than i did but we fixed her up
that's so great didn't win she didn't
she go she didn't win
the contest wait the contest was whoever
won about to go to hollywood something
like that yeah and we all got on the
street car to go down to the rko house
now that's a good story that's a good
story that's a good story number 17 18
years ago
the streetcar wow
in
rochester there's a streetcar
yeah
you